Facebook is unveiling a new so-called
war room to help deal with urgent
threats in the upcoming midterms and
prevent election interference the social
media giant says the war room will
streamline decision making if threats
emerge Facebook disabled more than a
billion fake accounts between October
2017 and March 2018 it also doubled the
number of people working on safety and
security and partnered with third-party
fact checkers to limit the spread of
misinformation Facebook's head of cyber
security policy and Nathaniel glacier
joins us good morning good morning so
are the midterms going to be protected
the thing that I'm most confident about
is that we've done everything we can to
make sure that that's true it's always a
challenge because they're always going
to be people when you have a public
debate leading up to an election that
are gonna try to target them we have
lots of different kinds of information
some of it is obviously made-up its fake
heads put on different bodies that kind
of thing that seems to me to be
something you can figure out put a lot
of bodies on it but what about the gray
or stuff things that are differences of
opinion that then get jacked up into the
conversation through some of these
methods which seem to be a lot harder
because if you take it off somebody's
gonna say wait a minute that's my point
of view one of our key approaches is you
can focus on the content that is what's
being said but you can also focus on the
behaviors what we found is that there
are certain tactics that bad actors use
again and again for instance using fake
accounts using what we call fake
engagement that is trying to make posts
look more popular than they really are
and trying to conceal their identity and
so when we take action take people down
like we did last week and we've done
over the last eight months ten months
we're acting based on their behavior
often and that is really valuable when
you get into this gray area right
because now you're not reading content
you're not thinking about whether
something is true or not they're
engaging in these techniques to
manipulate people and to confuse people
I always can all agree we don't want I
was stunned to read that Facebook has
taken down more than a billion fake
accounts and that's through March of
this year have you said how many
additional accounts you've taken through
down from March 2018 to October 2018 we
haven't released that yet we have a
periodic transparency report and it
hasn't come out yet with that update
hundreds of millions new you want to
release it today we're listening
yeah but here's what I mean there's
about seven billion people in the world
right and you're talking about a year
span there were 1.2 billion fake
accounts who's creating these fake
accounts are they foreign governments so
that report actually covered about six
months yeah and the key is that these
are fake accounts that are created often
in an automated fashion and so they
might be spammers they might be people
trying to perpetrate fraud some of them
might be nation-states and we have
automated systems that will detect and
remove millions of fake accounts every
day and something like 98% of the ones
we remove we do that automatically in
progress if everything I asked can I
just sorry to follow up on that just
because these fake accounts and some of
them then are real accounts for instance
in Myanmar I mean this was the front
page in The New York Times which
reported that military personnel in
Myanmar used Facebook as a tool for
ethnic cleansing this is not just
spreading fake news they used it to
incite violence to get people to kill
hundreds of thousands of Muslims in
Myanmar what happened in Myanmar was
horrible and we have been really focused
both in the United States
internationally and in countries like
Myanmar and anyone who's trying to use
the platform to facilitate
misinformation or to drive violence what
we need and what everyone wants I think
is authentic public debate on a platform
where you know who you're talking to you
know what they're trying to say and
you're able to build connections that's
what Facebook really enables and that's
the positive that it brings obviously
when you have a community like this any
new form of media there going to be
people who try to misuse it and who try
to manipulate it and so that's why we
have our teams that's why we have the
effort like the war room and all the
teams and the investments we've made
over the last several years to make sure
that we help encourage all the positive
and we minimize the threats like that so
let me ask you about this war room so
are the people there detecting bad
actors and why should we trust them to
do that what we've done is we've brought
together about 20 of the teams across
Facebook that are the core of our
efforts to detect bad actors so we have
our threat intelligence teams that run
our manual investigations we have our
data science teams that are looking at
the big picture and trying to see
patterns and also we work with our
outside partners whether you're talking
about people from government state
elections officials other companies who
might see things see threats and provide
information to us you've got a billion
pages do you have enough people to
detect all of that how many people are
gonna be in this actual war room you
could never fit all the people who work
security that's right you know you've
got four major public funds that hold
shares in Facebook that are calling for
the removal of Mark Zuckerberg its
chairman and I'm wondering what you
think about that I dare you to say yes
Gail I actually think that's a very good
idea but I do want to know what do the
people at Facebook think about the
leadership that's in place right now
I mean in my world so my team and the
teams that I work with who really are
very focused on the election that's
coming up this is something that mark
has been pretty vocal about he's
emphasized how important it is how
serious it is and so we're all pulling
together on this and one of the things
that's great is we're starting to see
results we've had about a dozen major
takedowns where we've identified and
removed information operations from the
platform over the last year we have the
Wharram set up now and to sort of
compliment the people in the war room we
also have automated systems that are
doing automated analysis to help us deal
with just the scale of Facebook all of
those things pulling together we're
starting to see some results you think
the question about mark marks at
leadership I think particularly in the
area where I work mark has had
incredible leadership this is where I
work so this is where we would fit
together it was your aha moment though
we call it at the Oprah Magazine because
for a long time they said Facebook
really didn't take this seriously what
was the aha moment were you guys finally
said okay we got to do something here I
mean we've said pretty clearly that
particularly leading up to the 2016
elections we weren't focused broadly
enough on the types of threats people
might use we were too focused on
traditional cybersecurity threats that
election and what happened after that
was a real wake-up call for us and since
then we've really been laser focused on
all the different ways someone could try
to misuse the platform and all the
resources we could bring to bear to
tackle that challenge well thank you so
much for being here I hope you'll
continue to update us and everything
that Facebook is doing it's important
thank you thank you very important
you're glad to see you